الى مزيد من الصعوبات انه هناك
بالمقاطعه فقط سيد محمد ساعتذر منك اسمح
لي على المقاطعه ولكن هناك اصوات في
الواقع عنيفه جدا
لانفجارات اصوات انفجار عنيف في داخل
الخرطوم
سنستمع لهذه الاصوات كنا نتابع اصوات
انفجارات وكذلك اطلاق نار واقتتال داخلي
اصوات مدفعيه ولكن منذ قليل كان هناك صوت
الانفجار كبير هزه العاصمه الخرطوم ستبقى
العين على هذه الصور اعود لك سيد محمد كنت
تتحدث عن المساعدات ولكن لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه تختص فقط في المساعدات ام ان
عملكم كذلك موسع ويمكن ان
تقدم خطه
هناك انفجار ثاني طيب سيد محمد هناك
انفجار ثاني كذلك داخل العاصمه الخرطوم
ساترك لصوت الطبيعي نستمع قليلا واعود لك
سيد محمد ابقى معي لو سمحت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات